quoi jim corcoran joue avec la langue
française depuis plus de 45 ans et on
lui doit de nombreux vers d'oreille
c'est dans
je suis fier de chanter de parler et de
défendre la langue de miron originaire
de sherbrooke
jim corcoran a grandi dans une famille
tous m'ont parlé en anglais après avoir
vécu aux états unis pendant huit ans de
retour au québec en 1970 il décide
d'apprendre le français rené lecavalier
son discours sa diction son vocabulaire
j'étais emballé et j'étais aussi à
l'époque
enfin alain desjardin la langue
française lui a permis d'écrire de
grandes chansons comme on s'est presque
touché on se met presque connue
et un bloc de ma vie où je me suis
consacrée à une réflexion religieuse
mais avec beaucoup d'intensité
plusieurs années et la chanson c'est
presque touché c'est le bilan de cet
exercice là en vers l'au delà qui n'a
jamais retourné un appel à propos en
plus de composer des chansons du mco
recourant à partager ses coups de coeur
francophone pendant 30 ans à la radio de
siby si avec l'émission de radio à
propos il a fait découvrir un public
anglophone
les plumes émergentes de la chanson
québécoise 30 ans d'à propos
j'ai eu un plaisir fou de faire ce que
j'ai fait et de rencontrer les jeunes
intervenants de la dalle est jeune
artisan de la chanson québécoise
francophone toutes les langues peuvent
goûter bon question d'hygiène
d'entretien et de bon usage
le chanteur qui a été parfois définit
comme un anglophone qui chante en
français a reçu mercredi l'ordre des
francophones d'amérique francophile
c'est un pas dans la bonne direction et
maintenant avec l'homme des francophones
je suis considéré a fait est dorénavant
comme francophones d'amérique sans pris
du temps mais je suis ravi pour ça que
je t'aime
toujours aussi passionné par les jeux de
langue du corps car en songe maintenant
à composer de nouvelles chansons
quelqu'un
quelques pas à quelque chose a dit je
m'excuse de voir mes guitares but est de
les avoir négligé et régulièrement les
freins dans mes bras je me minuscule
je me rendors ici louis fait des primes
est gras du cadam orient points